all right
looks like we're now live for the
december ama so i've already got a few
questions here
some pretty uh complex philosophical
questions it'll probably take me a
little bit of time so that's good
because that leaves other people
a chance to ask their questions i'm
going to remind everybody who's watching
i probably should do this at several
points that if you're
asking a whole bunch of questions i'm
going to answer one of them and then
move on to some other
viewer you don't need to ask a question
more than once
to get it into the queue as a matter of
fact that's
sort of like wasting everybody's space
if i do if i don't get to your question
it's not the end of the world
i get a lot of questions in here
especially towards the middle to the end
part of these things
so uh pair obazion says do you have a
position
on mind-body dualism um i mean kind of a
position
i mean it's not it's not an area that i
do a lot of
work on and i don't usually think of
like
you know my position as like what is
your position on
this topic and this topic and this topic
putting things together as if
it's a wikipedia article or something
like that
um i would say that
you know i tend to view things in terms
of there being something
distinct that we're not reducible to our
bodies
um but you know you can you can have
that sort of view without going into
like super hardcore dualism a la
descarte or something like that
um and you know i would say
i i incline towards the view that bodies
and materiality are quite important
that the relationship between whatever
we're calling mind or soul or spirit
and bodies is not a simple juncture
but actually quite complex even
descartes you know talks about this
in his correspondence with princess
elizabeth and with a few other people as
well
that um it's not it's not something nice
and
simple the way that textbooks often
present it or the way that
i think some philosophers would like it
to be and that's really about all i have
to say
on it um i i'm you know rather skeptical
of ai
projects that think that we're going to
you know
reproduce consciousness or or something
like that but
i don't know there's there's a lot more
to be said about that
uh johann says howard thinkers like
maurice blondell gabriel marcel henry de
lubeck respond to charles taylor's ideas
of the buffer itself and the imminent
frame
so the buffer itself is the idea that
you know we're less
permeable to things
transcending ourselves that we we
tend to be more isolated you know all of
those are thinkers who are writing in
modernity
so i mean this is this is a theme that
um blondelle and and and marcel
talk about quite a bit but they don't
use taylor's
uh language so if you look at their
their works they
they think that not being able so like
about
marcel's notion of availability or
disponibilite right or blondel's notion
of
of charity um it's a it's a capacity to
be open to
things while actually still remaining
integral yourself you don't want to just
like be
so open to things that everything takes
you over and transforms you into another
clone of itself
um you know i'm very
leery of these big generalizations about
modernity
that the modern self is like this i
think there's multiple modern selves
so i've never i've never really bought
into those
um sorts of sorts of generalizations you
know any more that i've bought into like
marshall mcluhan
all right uh lyra asks what can
philosophy teach us about dealing with
physical pain
philosophy is such nothing philosophies
a lot of things so
this is where you actually want to drill
down and ask
what philosophical traditions can be
useful
for dealing with physical pain and what
does dealing with physical pain mean it
could mean you know stop hitting
yourself in the hammer
in the head with a hammer so that you
don't have pain right stop doing certain
things or start doing certain things
that are going to make your body
have less pain but it can also be like
adjusting one's
mindset to to things and so there's a
lot to be said
in ancient philosophy particularly
stoicism
what we have of epicureanism
i think there's a lot there in the the
middle platonus tradition as represented
by somebody like plutarch
uh the aristotelians you know help us to
formulate
how to understand these things so you
know and then
this idea these ideas run throughout the
the history of philosophy many of whom
you know
like christian thinkers and early modern
thinkers are very conversant with
some parts of ancient philosophy and
also live in a time when analgesics are
not readily available
and so they they you know talk about it
quite a bit so i would say
it's it's not what philosophy can do for
you you know
capital p general thing it's it's
particular
schools that you want to look at as a
matter of fact there was actually in
stoicism today um
donald robertson and me and and one
other person
we actually went on a podcast and did
interviews about how to deal with
chronic pain
and what stoicism would have to uh
contribute to it
so all right alternative s what makes a
real philosopher in today's world when
is it right for one to call themselves
with that title there's no answer to
that i mean anybody can call themself a
philosopher if they want to
and a lot of people do and basically
they mean
that they you know like to generalize or
you know they have
a tendency towards
opining on things it's there is no
single answer to that sort of thing
and i think anybody who tries to provide
you with one is probably full of crap
um you probably want to look at who's
actually considered to be
you know um as a matter of fact
here's here's a better thing don't think
of it in terms of an on off switch think
of it like
somebody's more philosophical somebody's
less philosophical
right that might be helpful for you
but there aren't any absolute criteria
there's no agreed-upon definition of
philosophy there's something i talk
about in my
my philosophy classes at the very start
because otherwise people are going to go
to you know like the oxford english
dictionary says philosophy blah blah
blah and then you're like
don't rely on dictionaries let's not
help you
in a philosophy um i think that you know
you can call yourself by that title if
you
think that you're doing something that
answers to the name of philosophy and
other people can dispute that if they
want to
uh sean asks aj air once said the reason
he was not brilliant at philosophy was
because he did not know math
how important do you think mathematical
skill is for being a great philosopher i
don't think it's particularly important
it probably depends on what kind of
philosophy you're doing right
if you're doing if you're trying to do
work in the philosophy of mathematics or
foundations of logic you probably need
to
on it's not knowing math like being able
to compute or something like that
it's understanding the theories behind
it
um so you know being able to understand
how to put together
proofs for things and what constitutes a
good proof
but you know air was writing in a time
and a milieu
in which philosophy was quite enamored
of mathematics and so
he probably had a little bit of an
inferiority complex that he didn't need
to have
in in relation to it um
dale says do i have any thoughts on the
practice of meditation and mindfulness
in today's society
yeah as a matter of fact i'm teaching a
class next semester for milwaukee
institute of art and design called
philosophy mindfulness and life
so what we can say is that meditation
and mindfulness
can be done in a number of different
ways that it's not
simply an eastern or non-western
practice
it's something that you also find i mean
stoics call it prosoque right
attentiveness so it's something that's
used quite a bit
in a number of different philosophical
and wisdom traditions
i would say that a lot of what what it's
called mindfulness today is kind of
watered down
stuff and they're trying to you know
strip it of its they're usually getting
it from buddhism and they try to strip
it of its its
religious commitments so that it can be
more
general but you lose something in the
process that said you know some of the
activities can be quite useful but i
think that
mindfulness and meditation tend to
produce their greatest dividends when
they're within a substantive framework
right so you know
you can say the same thing about
techniques that are drawn into
psychotherapy
in other ways like reframing exercises i
think they work better when they're in a
more philosophical or religious
framework but you know maybe i'm wrong
about that
it's just my observations i would say
there's a lot of
people out there peddling garbage
mindfulness and meditation
but there's a lot of people out there
peddling garbage everything you know
there's there's uh you know you tell
whether something is effective
by seeing whether it provides you with
substantive guidance for for your life
that actually
pays off so the
business coach slash self-help kind of
embrace of
ideas from meditation or mindfulness
sometimes that can be good but
you often want to go beyond just just
that
all right uh c.s i find it depressing
how much we generally forget of what
we've read any thoughts on this
i used to get depressed about that sort
of stuff and now i don't and i think
that what happened in the process is
that there's there's
two things one is that um if you're
reading and you're not like speed
reading like the kind of person who's
trying to like
get in the books and like have mastered
this and master that but you're actually
like reading
um sort of like for the long term
reading slowly thinking about what
you're doing you'll be surprised
how much of the stuff that you think
that you've forgotten when it's
when it's properly reawakened in your
mind will
will come back to you eventually and
you'll be like holy crap
i uh i thought i'd totally forgotten
about that but now i realize that this
is the case
and another thing that you can say is
you need to read a lot
right the more that you read just like
the you know if you want to become a
good writer
write a lot if you want to become a good
reader read a lot
and read stuff that challenges you um
but don't be some sort of you know
snobbish
elitist about it who you know only reads
the
tough modernist novels it's okay to read
you know sci-fi
and fantasy and and uh i don't know if
you're into romance novels i don't read
that
that but people are are you know people
like those they could be good too i
suppose right
um and so you could you could retain
quite a bit and then you know
i would say the other thing that
probably for me changed is
as you go on through life and you
accumulate
more and more of this stuff in your
memory banks that
isn't getting you know accessed all that
often
you reach a point where you're like well
i don't remember everything
and maybe i don't even remember 10 of
what i've read but that's still pretty
good
you know that's still it's not nothing
it's
i don't have to have ideal you know uh
memory or anything like that like they
have on these characters on tv
who are complete fictions right i don't
need anything like that
in order to be okay you know i'll
actually tell you a funny thing that
somebody said about me in grad school
that i've said here before
i would often like be like oh yeah
that's that's in this book here and all
that and
one of my friends said yeah greg hasn't
really read a lot
he's not well read in that sense but
what
what he you know what he has read he's
actually paid close attention to so that
was kind of nice
all right uh jeff bim well
bimble venable do i consider
psychoanalysts particularly young to be
philosophers what if anything do you
think young has to offer
i'm not into young i think
psychoanalysts have some things to offer
but
i'm not i'm not a fan of jung so
i think jung is one of those things sort
of like william reich either
into him or you're not and i've always
found
jung to be rather implausible and
you know all of this archetype stuff is
kind of a neat bow to put everything
into
and i i've you know quite frankly
not been particularly impressed by the
people who are influenced
by jung by comparison to those who are
influenced by
um freud and his you know
other early psychoanalyst school
people and lacan and people like like
that
um and you know is is psychoanalysis a
philosophy
um it's it's philosophical adjacent
it's doing something different the idea
is to actually heal people
to fix people so i mean you could say
it's kind of like a philosophy of life
the pretensions to being scientific
i think have been blown out of the water
um
[Music]
and and that goes both for freud and for
jung and for
other offshoots as well but it doesn't
necessarily have to be scientific to be
usable for psychotherapy or
for other purposes but i think there's a
practical
purpose involved in psychoanalysis
when it's not just dilettantism right um
that you know that doesn't make it not
philosophy but it makes it very
different than a lot of philosophy
i'm somebody who's willing to extend the
term philosophy quite broadly
to encompass way more than what we
typically bundle under
the discipline's name in academics
and you know um what does psychoanalysis
have to offer
theories about the human self and its
development
and its relations to others through
culture
understandings of traumas understandings
of ways things go
go wrong i would say those are those are
often quite helpful and can be
great supplements for virtue ethics
but you always got to be careful you're
not you're not just like cobbling two
things together you've got to be
um you got to be dialectical in the way
you approach it meaning you've got to
see got to sift things out and see what
actually
works so like you know the oedipus
complex i think that was
nonsense from the start you know you
read something like that and you're like
how did so many people get taken in by
this this idea
you know um but there's a lot of other
things that that could be quite useful
so yeah all right let's
move on to the next
um
lord roku we're reading atheism and
christianity from ernst bloke in our
philosophy class are you familiar with
him not familiar
i i remember reading him back in grad
school but i don't even remember what i
read so
no xenovalea can suffering be overcome
i don't know what you'd mean by by
overcome
um you can certainly find ways to deal
with suffering
but if you mean like can you banish
suffering from
human existence probably not
eric ritzen's all what is hermeneutics
interpretation
you know that's what it essentially
means interpretation of signs
um there's a number of disciplines that
are connected with it
richard elliott how important is it to
have a goal or purpose when tackling
philosophy or anything i guess
um
i mean you you've always got some goals
or purposes otherwise you
you wouldn't be in an engaging in an
intentional action
i guess the question would be whether
they align with the
activity of studying philosophy and you
could have a lot of different goals or
purposes
some of them could be kind of extrinsic
to the discipline but they might
provoke you to to learn like you could
be
i want to become a rich famous
philosopher which is
not going to happen most likely right so
i'm going to study the history of
philosophy and i'll write the ultimate
book
i mean that could lead you into studying
right
uh you could also be like people have
been calling me stupid i'm going to show
them
i'm that i'm not stupid i can understand
kant or you know hegel or whoever
um that could be uh a goal or a purpose
um i think you probably have a number of
different goals or purposes and we
as human beings we're these messy things
that have a number of different
um things going on within ourselves that
aren't always usually
perfectly aligned so you might have
goals or purposes that you don't
don't even realize you know like maybe
you're studying philosophy
without realizing that it could be
helpful for you to
make sense out of your your existence
and your relationships and have better
emotional responses
and that only comes to light as you're
reading it and you're like holy crap
this this is useful for that
so and i don't know that you have to
have the same goal or purpose
over time either it could it could
change
there's mark uh good to see you here
um is there any thinker i would never
teach on no matter how much i was
offered i guess you're imagining like
like
money right um
i don't think so i mean
there's there's teaching in the sense of
like
explaining the ideas and then saying
well here you go here's what they're
actually saying
now you make a judgment about whether
you think this is good or not
you know and i teach people who i
disagree with all the time you know
prime example of that is ein rand and
ethics classes
not only do i think that einrand is a
philosopher but definitely a third-rate
philosopher
who gets the history of philosophy wrong
and
um you know most of the people that i've
known that are into rand are kind of
kind of jokes as far as philosophy goes
but i teach her because i think it's
it's useful for my
students to engage with somebody who has
incredible cultural importance not only
now inside
the usa but also in a world sense
they're reading her in
in brazil apparently um
and you know it's good to know what's
what's what's um off base or wrong
right uh to be able to identify those
weak points i also teach content and i'm
not a conscience
although kant is considered far more
respectable right is there anybody who i
just simply
would not teach um
i can't think of a a person who would
come to mind
but you know there's there's the
prioritization thing you know people are
always like
why don't we have videos on spinoza
because i don't teach spinoza in my
classes
i have taught spinoza in the past i just
don't you know i don't find him that
productive to teach undergrads
um and i don't compared to many other
philosophers i don't find him
all that that interesting um
and you know there's nothing that's not
like i've got anything against spinoza
but we've got limited time so i just
don't i never get around to it i've got
video core concept videos uh sitting on
my desktop
on mac sterner [ __ ] pascal
um schopenhauer just haven't gotten to
him you know
um everything's a matter of priorities i
would say
all right um
let's see here robert sims who was the
thinker you recommended who fuses
aquinas and continental thought i
believe he was a christian
i don't know i i don't where did i there
that could answer a whole bunch of
people i don't know who who
um we're talking about here i mean
there's a whole bunch of
continental ptolemists who would include
ati angel so and jacques mariten
and bruno de salaj and
pretty much all these french and german
thomas would be considered continental
wouldn't they
um so i i have no idea
which like of the many video i've shot
like
1800 videos at this point i have no idea
which one you're
maybe referencing so but there's a ton
of
continental thomists out there so
all right zeno what do you think of
nietzsche's idea of the will to power as
compares to schopenhauer's will
i mean what do i think about it um
i think it's great it's a nice idea
i'm not sure what you're asking there so
let me move on to the next one
alternative let's say i read some
noteworthy person's opinion
on an issue i never thought about and i
agree with that opinion and make it mine
what do we do if that happens too often
and we feel inauthentic oh
okay um i guess you got a couple options
there
you could realize that most of our ideas
are actually derived from
other people but that we do you know the
process of applying them
and reinterpreting them and that's often
as close to
i mean having your own ideas is not what
makes you authentic
um responding in ways that
represent us you know coming out of
yourself and a certain kind of
consistency
i think that's more what makes you
authentic
so you could be like you know an
aristotle got everything right person
and still be
authentic and you know you're reading
aristotle all the time you're just
trying to
apply uh a sometimes useful sometimes
totally
outdated and antiquated set of ideas to
to
late modern life you know
you could be authentic in doing that i
actually thought at one time
when i was in grad school of writing a
novel and it was going to be called the
aristotelian it was going to be about a
guy
who um like solved crimes and stuff like
that
and was was essentially you know
relying on an aristotelian framework to
make sense out of the world
it's getting dark in here so i gotta
turn on some more lights
um so i wouldn't i wouldn't really let
that hold you back the key is to
to you know find ways to make the
philosophies
your own too and a lot of that involves
like going deeper into the philosophy
um lowcash says
what do you think a prospective phd
student should be doing before putting
in an
application for a phd well first of all
you should decide whether you want to be
a prospective phd student after
undergraduate or a master's student
i actually think it's it's foolish to go
right to the phd
after um the bachelors because you're
depriving yourself of the opportunity to
study
a lot of class you know in classes with
professors um and you know i've always
thought that this track of
i'm going to go straight to the phd and
that shows that i'm smart shows
exactly the opposite shows a kind of
imprudence and impatience but that said
if let's say you have a masters
or let's say you're you're a bachelor
who's jumping straight into a phd
program
so there's a certain given packet that
you have to have you have letters of
recommendations so you know find some
people that can
write good letters of recommendation
that you can rely upon to do it for you
you're gonna have to write a statement
usually one to two pages about
why you're applying what you're
interested in
why they should consider you what your
plans are
you have to have your transcripts you'll
have a writing sample
usually maybe one or two writing samples
and that's that you know that's usually
the bulk of what you're doing
and these applications processes just
like
applying for jobs in academia they are
essentially black boxes you have no idea
what's going to happen
once that stuff leaves your hands and is
on the
table of a committee whose job is to go
through
and get rid of you know some
right off the bat and then weigh some in
different ways
your your application might appeal to
somebody for purely idiosyncratic
reasons
may turn them off for that i would say
one of the things so one of the things
you should be doing is like
getting ready for rejection and
rejection that doesn't have
anything to do with you you know and
also opening yourself to the possibility
of
cool things happening that also may have
nothing to do with your own
merits you know um but the other thing
that you can do is like look at the
programs
and see who's teaching there if you want
to study with those people
what their emphases are if you have the
ability to get
background information on what's
actually happening in the departments
that can be very useful
one of the places i applied to i applied
to 10 different
graduate schools this was in 1994
when i was applying and i got accepted
at almost all of them marquette lost my
letters of recommendation
and then didn't bother to tell me
because they were such a mess over there
and i
adjust her over there because they're 12
blocks down down that way
um and then you know i told that to the
chair when i
ran into him at a coffee house and he
was pissed
the incompetence of their their people
especially when he saw my gre scores
because i had maxed one section
um depaul wrote me back
and said depaul's in chicago right
they're a major continental school now
they were at that time split between
analytic and continental they had a big
battle
and the analytics said screw you we're
out of here
and they wrote me back and they said we
don't have enough professors to have a
phd
program at this point in time so we're
not accepting any applications from
anybody this year
so things like that will happen you know
other places will
you know accept you but won't give you
any funding or they'll take forever to
get back to you because academics are
not good at
handling that sort of administrative
work you know
all right uh aspiring holistic sage i
was wondering what got i was curious
what got you interested in philosophy
so i was interested in philosophy before
i knew it was philosophy
i was always interested in you know
topics of uh what we would call ethics
and metaphysics and epistemology
and aesthetics you know without without
really having much of a
background in that um not being
introduced to it in a formal way
and i actually did take a philosophy
class in high school which
sucked it was terrible it was basically
memorize this memorize this we did we
used a
textbook that was by mark marvin or
martin gardner who was a writer for
scientific american
it wasn't very good
[Music]
and then i had another class in high
school i've told this story many times
mr lorenzo one of my favorite teachers
was a substitute he was teaching
sacraments
so he said i'm going to teach about
augustine which means i need to teach
about plato and aristotle first so we
spent half the semester on plato and
aristotle
and he taught in a philosophical way you
know
and then you know when i was in the army
um you know we'd get into all sorts of
discussions and arguments about things
that had philosophical
weight to them especially since we're
doing a lot of hurry up and wait
and there were some pretty intelligent
guys in my unit
a lot of really dumb guys too
and um you know i i picked i remember
picking up a book and i don't even
remember who wrote the book but it
wasn't
you know it was sort of like an overview
of of philosophical stuff and then the
other thing that was really
key was i got out of the army and i was
um
i was working in a restaurant and i
would read stuff that was kind of
philosophical
um like you know game infinite and
finite games
that book i also read the uh
zen in the art of motorcycle maintenance
and things like that
but then i got to uh to college because
i decided i didn't want to be working in
restaurants anymore
and not earning very much and
my mom's boyfriend told me declare a
major right away
so i declared philosophy because i was
like philosophy sounds cool and i just
kept taking philosophy classes
and i liked the stuff and um you know i
also
liked literature and history and the
humanities writ large and
i also majored in mathematics um
in part because i loved the theory
involved and uh
you know i just kind of wandered into it
haphazardly there wasn't any
there wasn't any like moment when i you
know
picked up this book and and the way a
lot of people tell their origin stories
this is a bunch of random things i guess
you could say
all right um useless projects what made
me want to create more albert camus
content i just wanted to say i really
enjoy them happy you made new ones
uh you know i was trying to follow
through on a commitment that i'd made
i last time that i taught existentialism
for my milwaukee institute of art and
design students i shot
a series of videos on camus myth of
sisyphus
core concept videos and i didn't get to
shooting all of the ones that i had
scheduled because i
ran out of time and so i was like well i
got to shoot these sooner or later
teaching it again this semester my class
is just finishing up
with camus
let's see we're on saturday they're
finishing up tomorrow
so i needed to have those videos for
them and that's what made me come back
to it
i still have more i have to shoot on
myth sisyphus
to cover all of the topics in it and
i'll probably put together
a online class that people can
purchase uh in my teachable
study with sadler academy just on on you
know
camus myth of sisyphus and i'll probably
do some of his other works as well i
want to do the rebel
down the line and letters to a german
friend and
quite a few other things so i think he's
actually a
great thinker he poses some really
important problems
i don't agree with him on some of the um
positions that he takes but
you know i like him so
right ryan i like to look at things in
terms of spectrums i started doing this
because of being so interested in
political theory
is this a good way to look at different
subjects spectrums as opposed to like
on off like either it is or it isn't
yeah it's it's a good way to look at a
lot of things some things really
are either it is this or it is isn't
this
but i think there's there's a lot of
things where people assume that
matters are a lot more binary
than they are rather than being being on
a spectrum
you know like goodness for example right
goodness is uh
it's not like you cross a threshold and
suddenly become good
you know and there's good for different
things too so we could say there's
multiple spectrums going off in
different ways
alternative how do you deal with
difficult to understand
books um
i don't know i just keep plowing at them
i guess
i'm not a good person to ask about that
because almost nothing that i would say
about what i do is
is gonna be all that helpful for other
people
there's a lot of people who are like oh
you should try out this method or this
source
if if i have trouble reading something i
just read it again
and keep reading it and at a certain
point i can be like
well i'm not going to figure this out
and it could be either because the book
is
is actually when you get down to it
incoherent or gibberish
or it could be because it's just making
you know
there's too many things that i don't
know the reference to and i'm not going
to take the time to look them up
or it could be that it's actually beyond
me um
but i i find that you know so a great
example is
i've got this down on the floor so you
know all of you know i've been
doing the half hour hegel videos right
and that's the
phenomenology of spirit which by the way
i don't recommend
is the first book of hegel that you read
i don't know why people always want to
jump into that
when if you really want to understand
hegel you want to start out with
some of his lectures where he actually
names the names and tells you what he
what he's talking about instead of all
these tangential
references so you want to look at his
like lectures on the philosophy of
history or lectures on the history of
philosophy or you could even like read
his aesthetics or
you know philosophy of religion or
whatever um but
you know there's there's some days where
i'm getting ready to shoot
you can see my video equipment in the
back right the tripod and
cameras and the chalkboard and there's a
camera and i you know i'm going through
paragraphs of this
and i'm like okay i think i have a good
idea what the hell is going on here
and i think i've got some ideas about
what i'm going to say and then i start
writing on the chalkboard
and then sometimes i get in front of the
chalkboard and i'm like
it's not happening today i just lost my
my understanding there's there's some
days where
this is is impenetrable to me
and there's other days when it's not and
that's the way it is i think for most
people
um so there is one actionable bit of
advice
if you think if you think that the book
is too difficult for you at
a given time maybe put it down and come
back to it another time and
see whether you have the same experience
or not so
jamie brent opinion on kabbalah i have
no opinion on kabbalah
i don't really care about it
uh nausea what do you think of
nietzsche's critique of stoicism i did a
whole video on that
you can watch that video and see what i
think
eric says what's your view on the idea
of imminence i don't have a view on the
idea of imminence
you know these some of these things are
a little bit too like uh
vague i have no idea what you're asking
about
um let's see here made of clay
been trying to understand quentin
skinner's liberal conception of freedom
is non-domination and republican freedom
is the ability to act on this freedom
i keep getting confused between the two
because it's hard to find good examples
that differentiate between the two
i haven't read skinner for years i was
mostly reading him when i was doing a
lot of work on hobbs so i can't really
help you out on there
doing a lot of punting right now
all right noe says
what do you think of a law prohibiting
or limiting the recording of a police
operations like the one being passed in
france
so that's that's one i can talk about i
think that those are terrible laws
i think that the only reason to enact
those
is to protect the police and the
question that we can ask
is are do the police already have enough
protection
i don't know about france i suspect they
probably do in france i can tell you
that we
they have way more protection than they
need here in the united states
that we need way more transparency and
way more accountability
of police and we also need way more
if the cops want to say oh it's just a
few bad apples well they better come
down
hard on those bad apples because
otherwise you know with the metaphor
a few bad apples spoil the bunch right
so i i think personally that um
these these laws attempting to protect
the police officers
are really just catering towards the use
of force it's it's a way of trying to
have a citizenry
who will be easily intimidated
and we have way too many laws like that
here in the united states already so
many things that that tip the balance
towards
um the police and whoever happens to be
in charge at the time
so all right mark do you see human
president haley sanchez needs to
restrain for people to get along or on
the other hand basically good and
cooperative
yes both
see i don't see human nature in this
sort of binary it's either this or
this human nature is really really
complicated
you know there's a lot of moving parts
in
and we have both of these motifs you
know
in involved and some people they're you
know it's more expressed and in some
cultures
uh other parts are more expressed so
yeah
um all right let's see if we can find
somebody i haven't taken already
um well the first one like that is
asking about g-shape what do i think
about
like i'm not i'm not at this point in
time i'm very uninterested in ggek
uh you know i started reading his stuff
and
i think that over time his stuff has has
gotten sort of like with derrida you
know
starts out very rigorous eventually
you're like is this worth the time for
me to read
probably not you know so i think i think
he's
certainly made himself into a celebrity
but
you know every time that he comes out
with a new book i'm like do i want to
spend the time to
to read this or do i want to read any
one of the many other things that i i
could read
[Music]
um anthony says thoughts on brad
gregory's the unintended reformation
haven't read it so kampar
how do you read material from people you
really disagree with let's say mineconf
i just can't i mean i do read minecomp
to see what what hitler had to say and i
read other far
right and authoritarian and frankly
fascist or national socialist or
integral nationalist figures
and i've been doing that for years and
years and years because i want to
understand
um you know what what they actually
thought which often and why it could be
appealing
it often tends to be quite a bit more
sophisticated than the caricatures that
we give of it but then you can also like
see where
the the uh mistaken assumptions are and
where
the you know um problems arise and where
you know where it's sort of a slide in
evil
how do you read people from who you
really disagree with i don't know
um maybe some people can't i know that
there's a lot of people
who think that you really basically only
do philosophy by reading people that
that you align with and you're supposed
to read around until you find the people
that you do agree with
as a matter of fact there's a lot of
people who get into stoicism this way
and it tends to be a sort of superficial
attachment because they read a few
things that are like yeah man this is
exactly what i think
and then they if they'd read further
they'd be like no epictetus doesn't
agree with you on a lot of stuff and
seneca would say that you're you're off
base on this you know the books should
challenge us
and sometimes books can challenge us
towards the good
you know like when you read boethius for
example
somebody who i'm going to be shooting
videos on this month you know and you
work your way through the consolation of
philosophy and try to figure out
what the hell does he mean about you
know eternity and fate and all this kind
of stuff
the book challenges you the book brings
you into it
augustine talks about this actually
gabrielle marcel also talks about this
as well the difference between problems
and mysteries
um and there's other books that
challenge you in in other ways they're
sort of like [ __ ] in the bar
spouting their [ __ ] and you can like
say
that's [ __ ] and punch them in the
face and throw them out
or you can like sit down and listen to
them and see what they have to say
and still be like well you're you're
still full of crap or you're you're a
terrible person or something like that
um but you might also you know see
tendencies within yourself that that
connect up with that so
all right austin says applied
psychoanalysis provides results to
certain people particularly high trait
openness and temperament
insofar as his students i don't think
they can discover anything new he
cracked it open
yeah okay you're talking about jung um
i'll just take your word for that i i
don't find jung very interesting
um rishi with the rise of conspiracy
theories like q anon it almost feels
like some of us live in a different
reality
i was wondering how you think philosophy
could be used to help deal with these
people
it can't um you need other other means
rather than philosophy many of them you
should accept are unreachable at this
point in time
you know and and what's dangerous is
that we've got there's always some
lunatic fringes out there
um but now we've got a big lunatic
fringe
q anon is like mental poison and
anybody who starts buying into that they
start buying into all sorts of other
crazy nonsense as well
which makes them unhinged and
irresponsible
and dangerous quite frankly and
you know what you can do is you can keep
you can keep like asking them questions
and reaching out to them but you can
you've got to accept that most of these
people are just not going to be
reachable
what it'll take is some sort of crisis
you know sort of like kova deniers right
all these republican cova deniers who
are like oh i think it's a hoax and all
that and then they get it or their kid
gets it and they're like
i was so wrong about this and you're
like what an [ __ ] you are
you only changed your opinion because it
directly affected you
you wouldn't bother to look at what all
the other stuff had to say
about it was you were like in denial
and you know so it's still good that
they changed their view
but it's not a really good reason to
change their view that somehow they got
bit in the ass by it or you could think
about like gun nutters
who are you know they their kid kills
themself
and you know playing around with their
their unsecured gun
they're one of 20 guns that should be in
the safe that they blew all this money
on that they could have been spending on
like getting their family out of debt or
you know pursuing an education
and that suddenly they're like now i see
the light and it's perfectly legitimate
to say
well it's great that you see the light
but you're a [ __ ]
and you're still a [ __ ] and you're
going to be a [ __ ]
um until you like adapt yourself to
something that isn't just about your own
uh emotional needs and selfish interests
and and
you know wanting to be part of a club or
ideology or
be mean to other people i think the q
anon stuff
is is like that it's you know there's
there's a great article and i don't
remember
who wrote it but they are talking about
it as a new religious movement
that is dead on it is a religious
movement it is a
it is a sect and you're not going to be
able to
as an individual reach a lot of people
in that sect
what you can do is provide a place for
them to go if they do come out of it you
know sort of like what we do with cults
so all right uh
just skipped a bit let's see what we got
um
here we go um
nausea 56 as somebody asked us every
time thoughts on jordan peterson
what is there more to say on jordan
peterson he uh
he's revealed himself as kind of a joke
people who
buy into his stuff are kind of a joke at
this point
uh he was quite popular for a while the
way that we often see these these pop
you know psychology figures rise he tied
in with a certain
right-wing mentality and
there we go you know i mean what else is
there to say
i've said stuff about it many times um
silmas sheamus maybe broderick are there
any philosophies
philosophers that are particularly
pertinent to trauma recovery
um i mean existentialism
you know i would say can be helpful
there's nothing that's like directly
relevant to it
unless there's like philosophy of trauma
out there which i don't know you know
maybe maybe there are some philosophers
who are writing
explicitly directly about this but
there's all sorts of
people who are writing sort of in
alignment with it you know
it depends on what the trauma is coming
from i suppose
um you know you could think about
critical philosophers
whether they're feminist or anti-racist
or stuff like that
there's often a lot of discussion of
trauma in there
um but i i think sometimes even like
it's not easy if you can directly apply
it but you could think about
um you know like aristotle what he has
to say in nick and mccain ethics book
seven
about the difference between brutality
and vice and he uses as an example of
that
children who have been sexually abused
that was a problem even back then
and the things that it induces so you
know there's there's a whole bunch of
people that might be useful um
sean hamill as a christian do you think
the spread of christianity was based on
complete historical contingency
or do you believe it was due to a divine
plan why would it be one or the other
if you actually think there's a
providential ordering it
happens at least the way that you know
traditional
christian thought has has talked about
this through
contingent events so you know
all right uh gabriel what are some good
starting points and mindset to become
politically educated in today's
polarized
society um hmm that's a that's a good
question
politically educated so you know it's
good to have
i'd say political education would would
consist of a couple different things
one would be learning some history
right learning the history of where
different
political ideologies have come from and
why they're attractive and not just
recent stuff but you know going back a
ways
and doing some comparative work as well
political theory would also be good to
learn about you know
even if it's not directly applicable to
the situation that you're in
it it broadens your your point of view
and allows you to be able to
to think these things through
um yeah i think that's pretty much all
that i've got to
say about it um
eric asked do i view deluge as a kind of
anarchist
kind of anarchist is a good descriptor
yeah very suspicious of power structures
of the law
but realizes that we can't totally get
by without them
either you know a lot of people think of
anarchists as like they want to get rid
of
all rule and that's not that's not
always the case i mean anarchists are
kind of a broad
mixed group right some of them want
some of them want to replace coercive
power relationships with
um power relationships that that people
could get behind that would be you know
mutually beneficial or things like that
um
i mean deleuze is not an anarchist in
the sense of let's tear everything down
or anything like that he engages a lot
of recuperative
projects in the history of ideas you
know
um this is a good one
q says thoughts on sam harris and jack
peterson
require a bot in chat to automatically
answer them
at this point that would be quite useful
we could load in like you know the
top 10 uh thinkers that i always get
asked about
um and and i don't really care much
about
that that would that would be quite
quite useful wouldn't it
sorry says in all caps why are not
generated new social scientific ideas
today
who says there aren't i mean
there's there's there's continually new
stuff coming out
um it's hard to stay on top of all of it
because there's so many people working
in the humanities but
i i'm not sure why you would say there
isn't anything being
new um
alternative says we study the symposium
at uni my professor seems to agree with
everything but to me it seems like some
people are meant to love and be loved
and others don't what's your opinion on
that
so you couldn't agree with everything in
the symposium because the characters
disagree with each other
um to begin with maybe you mean that he
agrees with everything socrates and
deotima are saying
some people are meant to to love and be
loved in others
not um
i mean it depends on which person's
position you're taking in the symposium
right if you're taking aristophanes
then there is a match or mate out there
for us or at least a facsimile of them
if you're talking about you know
what what socrates has to say in the
latter of
loves you're actually moving away from
individuals towards
more universal things that you fall in
love with and then you love others
through that
um not everybody can do that um
if you're talking about pulsonius you
know the there ought to be a law kind of
guy or the laws are actually kind of
screwy
who only talks basically about about um
laws governing um sex between men and
boys
um he's already taking a very exclusive
point of view right so
yeah thomas says
what kind of fictional literature do you
recommend that's also philosophical
classical modern existential well there
are the existentialists right so
kafka is quite philosophical dostoyevsky
has characters arguing philosophy
um and you know speculative fiction is
quite good for that sort of thing
depending on who the author is right
some some have more like philip k
dick or isla kayla green octavia butler
um cj chera you know those are examples
of
of um people who are really working out
a lot of philosophical ideas
frank herbert right um
maybe some aren't the schlocky writers
you know or they've got
ideas that aren't aren't particularly
interesting or
great but i mean the world of
speculative fiction has tons and tons of
stuff
prohem is there any idea or thinking you
think is understudied in philosophy
literally thousands so yeah there's
always going to be kind of a faddishness
to things
and we don't want to take who
are in the academic journals or who are
being taught
in departments as an index of the value
there's always people that are being
overlooked
doll liquor do you think do i believe
there's anywhere in particular
in heidegger's work where he misses the
mark is false or proposed something you
significantly disagreed with yeah plenty
of stuff in being in time
you know the way in which he handles
tradition
and um you know his his deliberate
decision to say that any sort of moral
or ethical concerns are already sort of
like putting you know blinders on
there he's in like complete opposition
with somebody like mock shaler
who is a contemporary of his and just as
good as heidegger and just as important
in the phenomenological movement so
yeah thinker what do you think of the
teaching profession
is it the proper route for someone who
loves philosophy and is philosophically
minded um
if you're talking about the academic
teaching profession here in the united
states
where we don't have people teaching
philosophy in
high school except in you know a few
religious schools
and in as an elective
in a few really well-funded public
schools
and you're talking about the you know
universities and colleges we have right
now
this is not a great time to be trying to
find jobs in academia places are cutting
marquette university
just down the street is firing 450 staff
and faculty
this semester all the visiting assistant
professors have been fired
they're going to start cutting into the
departments now another one of the
places that i teach much smaller
carthage college
fired 15 tenured professors over the
summer
with one month's advance warning so
you know should you should you try to
get jobs in the academy
if you can get them and hold them you're
then that's great
the competition is incredibly stiff um
is it the proper route for someone who
loves philosophy and is philosophically
minded
there's no proper route there's a whole
bunch of routes and you can decide
what you think would work for you some
people even back when i was an
undergraduate it was common for people
to come out of philosophy
and then work for corporations as system
analysts
there's all sorts of jobs that you can
work with
a philosophy degree where you can
actually you know put your mind
to to work and do some cool stuff you
know
so i don't think i mean the teaching
profession is great if you can get into
it
and you like teaching and you're good at
teaching
if not uh it's probably going to suck
for you
you know so
all right um
isaac have you ever taught or considered
teaching the works of the frankfurt
school
i have taught them when i was teaching
uh like the whole curriculum for
a philosophy degree in indiana state
prison
i don't usually bring them in not
because i don't like them but because we
have limited time in
in the classes that i teach but i mean i
could do it i don't know i don't know
that there's that much interest
in it among students so
austin says how do rationalists find any
firm ground in philosophy when nothing
is intrinsically rational
unless imposed by an observer wouldn't
that be pragmatism
how do you know that that's a huge
assumption you're making there
is that seems like something you would
want to have some sort of
argument for rather than assuming
everybody has buy-in
on that um i mean they are the
rationalists provide arguments for the
positions that they take you know you
can find descartes
talking about that in the meditations
and and object you know some of the
objections and
replies and stuff like that um
anadi name some philosophical texts that
might help in working through regret
well that's where mock shaler could be
could be useful or
you know any of the other
phenomenologists
who who look at the human emotions
adrian pepperzak perhaps
[Music]
those those could all be interesting
lines to go down
you could also look at you know
treatments of emotions
in earlier um ancient philosophies like
aristotle or
you know the platonus tradition or the
stoic tradition you know
sometimes the regrets that we have are
not really
that rational and we can work our way
through them so
all right uh
let's see fur
with a lot of views sure what should i
be looking for in a piece of work
of mine that i might submit as a writing
sample just what i think is my best work
um well you definitely want it to be
what you think to be your best work
but you want to you know you want to
pick it if you've got a choice between
like
a writing you did on somebody really
obscure that not too many people are
familiar with
and writings on you know thinkers or
topics
that or problems that that more people
are probably
gonna know a little bit about and be
interested in
i would submit the latter right because
you're more likely to get it read
by people who think that you know it's
it's a topic
topic worth discussing so
i would i would add that to it
uh muhammad can you recommend some
workbook or anything around why is there
something rather than nothing question
i mean you know heidegger brings that up
a lot
right livenets um you know
uh any of the the thinkers that that
talk about god creating things
they usually have some reason why they
think god created things
that would be people dylan what are your
thoughts on psychedelics especially now
that
some substances like psilocybin might be
used for therapeutic practices
i think therapeutic practices and you
know philosophical stuff are two
separate things
um i i think that so i'll say this i
think that that people who are
like into drugs for the sake of being
into drugs are usually pretty boring
people
in my experience like and one of the
things that was a drag about
smoking pot was all the all the friggin
potheads
that you know pot will make you happy to
just sit around and do nothing other
than watch tv
all day you know and i found that really
boring when i was when i was uh
into stuff i was more into smoking and
drinking you know i liked uh
the taste and the effect of tobacco and
i liked uh
drinking i still drink every once in a
while i don't i don't get drunk like i
used to but i'll have a
drink every once in a while with my wife
or friends
um you know i enjoy the buzz that you
get
i don't enjoy hangovers now that i'm
older i can tell you that
um you know and and i never did any
um uh hallucinogenics and never really
wanted to
because most of the people who would
talk about oh it's gonna open your third
eye man
or you know show you reality or
something like that i never bought into
that that that sort of line i think it
can
you know it can make you see things in
different ways but
um i i think that if you want to like
understand reality you do it through the
old-fashioned ways
of working your ass off in terms of
you know harnessing the powers of your
mind i mean this is the the objection by
the way that
that practitioners uh uh you know
of hinduism and buddhism and things like
that made to adults huxley when he was
making these arguments
uh back in the 20th century
i think it's great if we can use you
know ecstasy
or or hallucinogenics or stuff like that
to help people
deal with ptsd or things like that but i
don't think there's much
philosophical use for the these things
you know so all right
um let's see who else we've got
rima where do you think someone should
start on horse roll
uh i i mean i always start students off
with
two things host roles cartesian
meditations
and his article that he wrote i think it
was for encyclopedia britannica perhaps
on phenomenology um i think those are
good starting points
but i'm not a hostile scholar i mean i
actually wrote my my
my master's thesis on just role and
dissociate and basically duplicated
without realizing what darien i had done
in speech and phenomena
um but after that i was like that's
enough hoose roll for me
you know i i i'll read him every once in
a while i've i've taught him
occasionally but i'm just not that into
his role
so um
[Music]
let's see here
sam see thoughts on the idea you can't
help people who won't
help themselves um
oftentimes it's used as a justification
for not helping people because you don't
know whether they'll help themselves or
not you probably need to try
but there are there i mean there are a
lot of cases where you can
do all sorts of things for people and
they will continue to like screw up
their lives and
lives of other people around them i mean
you can help people
against their will in some ways like you
know if they're suffering from an
infection you can give them antibiotics
and
not make it an option for them but
that's that only gets you so far
you really can't do there's certain like
thresholds you can't get past
unless people want to buy into it
all right um
giovanni is wittgenstein an important
philosopher
you know that's a really interesting
question i think the consensus
is that he really was considered to be
so in the 20th century
and he helped out with certain things
as i've mentioned in my my video on
wittgenstein he would have been so much
more powerful had he been better read
uh on his own part and not just read so
selectively
um it was it's interesting because
somebody actually asked on twitter
what is there in wittgenstein's works
that
is a substantive contribution to
philosophy that you can't find
in somebody else who didn't get it from
wittgenstein and people put a whole
bunch of different things and then other
people would be like
that's there in this person that's there
in this person
i guess with vic conscientious somewhat
like being in the right place at the
right time
and impressing the right people um
but i i tend to think that
he will certainly be talked about a lot
but he's not really
as important of a philosopher as we
we thought he was so i think you know
by the end of the you know this century
he probably won't be read that much
um all right let's see
aaron swanson it's funny you said
military service brought you to
philosophy in a lot of ways
i i didn't say that um all i said was i
i talked with guys and we'd talk about
things that were broadly philosophical
and i bought a book
so military service did not bring me to
philosophy but he says the same applies
to me when i was in the army
which actually brought me to anarcho
communism i'm
sure he had very different experiences
than than i did i'm glad that
you know being in the army was helpful
for you that way
um let's see here
tell says i was about to ask about
nietzsche i haven't seen the video but
my impression is that he's a hammer who
tried to destroy all myths
so his myth would prevail myth of the
genius i
i wouldn't i mean that's for me hearing
that it
there's i don't map that on to thinking
about nietzsche as a thinker at all
um so he didn't try to destroy all myths
as far as i can tell he's
certainly you know philosophized to the
hammer but that doesn't mean he
busted up everything so
chiao says i'm going to take philosophy
ethics next semester any guidance how to
make the class
easier ethics can be taught in a variety
of different ways i don't know how your
instructor is going to teach it
i i guess you could say you know the
same things that would apply to any
class stay
on top of the the readings
try to think about how you can apply
this stuff that you're studying
within the context of your own life
[Music]
but you know i i have no idea there's so
many different ways ethics gets taught
that i don't know
i don't know what i could really say
chris as you've mentioned before you
have some interest in systems theory
or is it systems philosophy novel in the
history of philosophy with the rise of
complexity science
i don't have an interest in systems
theory i have an interest in systems
which go which precedes systems theory
systems theory is a set of approaches
i'm not really interested in that i'm
interested in all sorts of systems
and in being systematic but that's not
the same thing as system theory
um sir sluggard are there any fictional
pieces that delves into philosophy that
you enjoyed
literally thousands um ranging from
you know as i mentioned philip k dick
and ursula kayla green
i'm rereading dick's martian time slip
right now
which is you know as awesome as when i
first read it
15 years ago maybe 15 years ago
um you know there's there's
literally thousands you could pick from
so
[Music]
uh let's see made of clay this is more
of a what-if question if one were to see
a police
brutalizing a citizen at what point
would this officer lose their authority
that a citizen could step in to stop
them
as soon as they begin brutalizing the
very word brutalizing
is is revelatory there right
um all right oh it just jumped again let
me see what we
got here um
[Music]
ren ends says i'm writing a paper as a
dualism response to prison
princess elizabeth's objection about
interactionism any suggestion for
responses from other philosophers
other than descartes himself um
responses to princess elizabeth
i don't know um response is more broadly
i mean
spinoza principles of cartesian
philosophy and then the ethics
is setting out one possible way to look
at it
you know the entire rationalist
tradition from that point on was very
interested in the mind-body
relation and and the french authors in
particular
you know merlot ponte maurice marilyn
ponte actually had
seminars on the um connection between
the mind and the body
in descartes manda beran
and bergson so this is this is a
topic that that really you know people
kept
approaching over and over again um
let's see here
so lorenzo says i have an irrational
disdain for kant that came from some
fellow students
what's an engaging intro to him that
might get me past my goofy disdain
um i don't know about intro to him
i i suppose do you mean like reading
secondary works
like you could read or nora o'neill you
know she's a great conscient of the
20th century um
i mean
when you read kant's stuff
i would say it's
clear that he's he's a great thinker um
we might not agree with what he's saying
but he's not stupid for what
what he's saying he is kind of stupid at
certain points right like you know when
he when he's
talking about um the morality of his
time and he's like oh you know
this is terrible and this is terrible
and all that but but there's there's a
grandeur to his thought
that runs past that and
um i don't know i mean you could take a
look at
take a close look at the groundwork for
the metaphysics of morals and then
and then read the metaphysics of morals
the med you know focus on the
metaphysical elements of
virtue before going to the metaphysical
elements of justice
it's really cool stuff and again you
know we don't have to necessarily like
agree with his way of
formulating things but there's there's
something there just like with hume
right
or descartes or a lot of these great
thinkers you don't have to
to agree with them to see that there's
something worth
studying there michael anderson do you
like schopenhauer
yeah i like schopenhauer he's an
interesting guy
i liked him well enough to take a
schopenhauer class as a postgraduate
with european graduate school when i was
there as a visiting scholar
and was given the opportunity to study
with wolfgang schumacher
the at that time president of the
international schopenhauer society so
yeah i like schopenhauer you know uh
he's not like in my top 10 i'd say
uh but you know he's he's cool
sire i've heard some interpretations of
peterson as a pseudo-stoic is that an
accurate description for you
i wouldn't even bother trying to connect
uh uh peterson with stoicism
um anybody who does doesn't know
stoicism so
it's you know it's just better to look
at him as just a
kind of traditionalist right-wing figure
you know um
basically a you know a guy who
you know went from being writing some
some crazy stuff in his first book
drawing on all sorts of archetypal
theory to you know
being popular by giving lectures that
were kind of you know
on point sometimes and then weren't got
embraced by the right wing
and then basically became the old guy
saying get off of my lawn and pull your
pants up
so yeah probably not worth worth
thinking about
um
let's see here
kevin says there will always be new ways
to worship money
i guess so lenny penny is eating animal
meat
unethical if so why um i would say that
eating meat that's coming from factory
farming definitely is because of the
horrific suffering it imposes
not only on the animals but also on the
workers
i mean i'm not a vegan or vegetarian
myself
we we actually pay quite a bit for
ethically sourced meat that we get from
butcher box
my wife and i and and she's she's
actually more
you know inclined towards uh veganism
than i
am um
i i think you could say that the way in
which we have allowed
farming to devolve under late capitalism
into factory farming is pretty horrific
so yeah
jordan tahami if you had to choose who
is the most important philosopher of the
20th century is it heidegger of
wittgenstein
the most important philosopher of the
20th century i mean how do we
define importance um
i mean i don't think it would be
heidegger or wittgenstein
um man i'd have to think about that
uh that's that's a tough one
all right um
eric says uh i'm currently reading the
latter works of foucault about ancient
philosophy and having some trouble
understanding the difference between
ethics
and the aesthetics of the self okay
i don't know what you're asking me to do
there um
i gotta say that myself as somebody who
who came to those works having a
grounding in ancient philosophy
some of the time i was like come on for
co you know this
this is a good insight i don't really
buy you on this
uh and i think a lot of people bought
when they read foucault they like
believe it hook line and sinker
um you don't have to accept his his
categories
uh necessarily um
i mean he's not using ethics in quite
the same way as we do in ethics
textbooks maybe that's
what's what's tripping you up you know
um
all right uh fou
dalden do you have any tips for someone
who loves philosophy and the knowledge
involved but doesn't like sitting down
for long periods of time to read
read in short periods uh read in many
short periods get up and walk around
once in a while
uh read by listening to audiobooks you
you often get different
perspectives by hearing it rather than
reading it but you know that's that's
what you could do
um i i don't know how you get around
like getting the information
um so yeah
let's see here paul says
following your hegel lectures susan buck
morses hegel haiti and universal history
is way cool have you read it
have not read it sounds interesting but
um
i haven't haven't read it um
andrea asks why don't you debate
peterson or someone else from the
idw uh it would be epic
i don't like debates i think the baits
are usually pretty stupid
and i think that that um they're usually
a waste of time i agree with et angel
song who is
you know involved early on in the the
christian philosophy debates who said
that people
generally aren't changing their minds
because of what's happening
in debates dialogue is far better
and then you have you know these these
obnoxious
characters who uh just want to debate
and basically have no interest in
anything other than trying to
win or you know show other people up
i just don't see it as a particularly
good
use of my scarce resource of time
that said if somebody wants me to debate
people they can
they can pay me you know if it's going
to be drawing my time away from things i
consider more valuable
and and you know making me work in a
format that i think is particularly
unproductive they can they can pay me
for that just like people who want
videos on a particular thinker can
commission me to produce videos you know
um nestor what are my thoughts on leo
strauss
interesting thinker i don't buy a lot of
what he has to say but i do
like to see what he has to say i think
that straussians are usually
you know not as good as as leo strauss
himself
they come in a couple different flavors
i've met quite a few
over the course of my career and have
been impressed with very few of them
um so you know
i guess that's all i have to say about
strauss
um
let's see here aaron says is mock shaler
who he said in addition to aristotle
about regret and emotion
and adrian someone so yeah mark schaeler
um
uh adrian pepperzak who i think
is retired now from loyola dutch
philosopher who's been here in the
united states for a very long time
did a lot of work on hegel on levynos on
phenomenology in general he's somebody
worth checking out
um let's see here
aaron asks about uh jean messilier i've
never read them so i don't know
let's see who i haven't read
a lot of back and forth here going on
hey bruce
nice to see you always good to
talk to to him um
who do we have that we haven't hit on
yet because we're getting close to the
the end time
badass [ __ ] what kind of music do you
listen to what is your take on the
philosophy of music so philosophy of
music is an area that i only know little
bits and pieces about you know
there's some interesting treatises
in in ancient and medieval philosophy
but we don't have a hell of a lot
of that stuff aristocenos
is a student of aristotle bashed
aristotle
but wrote wrote some interesting things
boethius and
augustine have interesting things to say
about music but a lot of it's not really
that applicable to
what we're dealing with in the present
aristotle and plato of course write
about the different modes
and what they can do um
my you know i listen to you can say here
here's here's my
my thing on music i'm a classic metal
head
so that means that i listen to a lot of
heavy metal from the 1970s
1980s some of the proto metal stuff like
jimi hendrix and cream
and blue cheer um and you know some of
those bands continuing on into the 90s
and
and beyond and then i also listened to
some
some genres of you know that include
more recent bands like
some some power metals some some doom
metal
and um yeah that's that's probably
it um so there's that whole range right
there and i know a lot about the history
of heavy metal i actually
i have a uh heavy classic heavy metal
class with my friend scott tarrouli and
we talk through the
these sorts of things and you know i go
to concerts with my wife
who's also a good sport about that
because she has a much wider range of
music that she likes but she also likes
metal
and so um there's that but then i
there's a lot of other things that i
like as well including some new wave
like i'm a big duran duran
fan um you know some post punk stuff
like new model army
i got into alternative music in in the
uh
90s for a while you know
i was i liked the grunge stuff i played
in cover bands that you know covered
pearl jam and nirvana
you know bands like that stone temple
pilots
um and i like a lot of you know older
stuff too like you know i'm a big fan of
gordon lightfoot for example
um and i'm not sure where it came from i
know my dad was a really
he was really into music and when i say
my dad i mean my adoptive dad who died
when i was 11
and left a lot of records behind he was
into jazz
and um you know folk music
and you know he would go to music
festivals we would always go to
summerfest down here in milwaukee i'm
pointing where
where the summerfest grounds are from
here no actually they're over there
that way um i you know like i remember
seeing paul revere and the raiders with
him when i was a kid
uh and then going into you know the
ferris wheel and stuff like that
so i should probably do a uh sadler's
stories about that
and you know i've picked up other
musical artists who i've liked
over over the years you know
some singer songwriters so so i listen
to
you know kind of a range my wife exposes
me to a lot of other
kinds of music that i ordinarily
wouldn't be listening to
um but i'm always coming back to classic
metal
you know that's that's my thing so
all right uh
let's see here
renzo asks about eugene thacker but i
haven't i haven't read eugene thacker um
jamie any ways or names you can point me
to read about the value of aesthetic
beauty
yeah i mean there's like a whole whole
bunch of philosophers
plato you know the symposium is about
beauty
tocadon aristotle of course has the
poetics
but other discussions of toca lon in in
other places
um platinus is is somebody who gets
brought up a lot
in aesthetics classes
there's quite a few other thinkers in
ancient times
augustine beauty plays a role in some of
his
thoughts really the whole neoplatonic
tradition i would say
it's important for them um
and then you know you can go all the way
through into modern times
you know kant has this the the third
critique in which he's trying to
figure out what makes things beautiful
you know german idealism is quite
interested in all these romantic writers
so there's lots of
lots of people you could point to
um let's see here
[Music]
trying to see if there's anybody i
haven't responded to
at least once yet um
galen in your aristotle video you listen
you listen see women
you list women maybe you think are good
aristotle interpreters thoughts on
martha nussbaum
i've got mixed feelings about martha
nussbaum she's
she's a you know she's a good scholar on
a lot of things
i don't always agree with her on stuff i
think she's
very i think she was very good at
self-promotion
and um there's there's other
scholars who probably better deserve
your time and attention
than she does she also
perjured herself deliberately in a court
case years and years ago
in a way that a classicist should have
problems with
um even for you know what what
to her seemed like a good cause so
you know she she's she's somebody who
you you have to engage
um but i don't i don't you know
maybe i should hold her in higher regard
i i'd say you know
if i have to choose between her and
margaret graver or julianas or
you know gizella striker or any of these
others nancy sherman even
i'll take them you know so
all right uh nestor what do you think
about great book schools such as st
john's college i think you know that's a
good approach for some people um
i think that they they're they're
interesting
i don't think it's the only way to do
great books obviously there's lots of
other programs out there
and
i i think that you know i i've met quite
a few people who have come out of the
saint john's
college uh either teaching or as
students and they all seem to have
liked it quite a bit it's just not a
model
that's readily available for most people
um
so it's almost like a utopia for
for the select lucky few you know
um b is candleness heavy enough is st
vitus worthy of beatification um
[Music]
i mean heavy enough sure yeah i mean
um they're not bands i listen to much
i mean i've listened to both of them
before but they're not they're not in my
like big list or anything um
marina says rise and fall of musical
subcultures have similar patterns to
rise and falls of various notions in
society they're quite hegelian in that
sense
sometimes they are sometimes they aren't
i wouldn't i wouldn't try to use
uh the bastardization of hegelian
dialectic
you know with the thesis antithesis
synthesis thing that people love
to try to make sense of it i think
things are way more complicated than
that
michael what philosophers do you
recommend reading to get through an
existential crisis
well i mean you could read some
existentialists
but it could be all sorts of things it
really depends on
what you're interested in and what your
existential crisis
is about you know some some philosophers
are going to have more to say to you
some are some people are helped out by
reading william james
others they're like i can't stand this
guy you know so there is i don't know
there's not enough
there's not enough information there to
to really say
um let's see what else i
got her got her grown tell us about the
stranger in the sophist he is the
selfish
right i don't agree with plato's actual
opinion like some say am i missing
something i mean i i wouldn't really
worry about whether he's
representing plato's actual opinion i'd
focus first on just getting
getting that's a complicated dialogue
you know wrapping your head around
what the hell are these forms and how do
they connect with each other i would
worry about that
that first you know um
let's see andrea marcovati what do you
think about social needs and the gulag
archipelago seem to be a mix of
historical stuff and unverifiable
anecdotes
to the point i think he might be
overrated well is the gulag
archipelago the only thing that
solzhenitsyn wrote
he also wrote one day in the life of
evan denisovich
the first circle by the way the first
book i ever read of him
the first circle because my dad had it a
whole bunch of short stories
you know a number of other things so do
we do we
judge him just by the gulag archipelago
or do we judge his work
as a whole um
you know why do we read seoul chinese
do we read social nets and just for the
historical stuff
or are we reading him for the asides and
meditations on the
human condition i'd ask yourself that
could be that some of it is [ __ ] and
fabricated and that it still could be
worth reading you know
so all right
uh here we go
let me find something to go out on
so a gym guy would you ever do a video
on albert camus the rebel it says one
work i could never find any information
on
um i wouldn't do a video i would do a
series of videos and it's you know it's
one of those things waiting for me to
find the time
um sort of like the question that epic
just asked that i
answered so many times why don't you
cover arthur schopenhauer
i haven't gotten to it yet you know for
everybody who's like
why don't you do a video on this person
you can commission me or get people
together to to commission me to do
videos on whoever the hell you want but
until then i do things on my schedule
and
you know i do it when i can and i'm
generally shooting videos for my
students
my academic students who have a priority
over other other uh fans right
um it's easy enough to get in touch with
me
people have done it and commissioned me
to shoot videos you know
so that's um
that's kind of a common thing here um
all right let's find something else to
go out on
uh stephen warren
what is the most beautiful work
of philosophy we read stylistically
that's interesting um
stylistically i mean if we think about
who are the really great writers
stylistically
it ain't aristotle you know and it's not
hegel
um i mean
nietzsche is especially when you read
them in the german is really good plato
is
really good um
[Music]
cicero too um i i really like cicero
um descartes you know i'm gonna pick
i'm going to pick descartes the
meditations
when you read it in the french
translation and you read it in the latin
it's pretty brilliant stuff
stylistically
so that's what i'm going to go out on so
all right uh good to see all of you
didn't answer everybody's questions but
i answered quite a few
and uh be having another thing tomorrow
on political theory and application
we're still talking about the aftermath
of the current election and
it's going out with a whimper rather
than a bang
at this point in time so maybe i'll see
some of you there
thanks everybody who joined and had some
questions
i'm going to be getting back to work
it's still
we're still in the semester and
i'm going to get myself something to eat
so
i will see you later on